hey 42 here your brain is a vast science
lab that is able to produce a
never-ending stream of chemical
concoctions that help fight disease
escape danger make you feel happy or
gently send you to sleep
that's right whether you like it or not
your neurological system is a massive
junkie and this is how external drugs
like aspirin cocaine meth and cake are
able to affect you your body already has
a receptor for a similar chemical so you
are just stimulating the reaction that
already existed within you this is why
drugs both legal and illegal have been
such a huge part of human history
whether it's communal experiences like
the ayahuasca used by Amazonian tribes
or even the communion wine drunk by
Christians drugs have created rituals
helped religions and fueled our
creativity of course they have also
destroyed communities send people crazy
and caused your friend Dave to keep
sharing all those conspiracy theory
memes there are no lizard overlords mate
lay off the weed and eat some vegetables
but how far does the influence of drugs
stretch throughout the development of
mankind today we look at the surprising
history of drugs
the biggest war of all time was largely
down to an Austrian man who believed in
purity not just racially but he was
renowned among his followers for his
self-discipline his unusual love of
animals and his general lack of vices so
it's pretty surprising to find out that
this was all a sham and it's possible a
Hitler suicide in 1945 was in part down
to severe withdrawal symptoms since
Allied bombings had cut off his access
to speed cocaine and opioids that he was
strung out on and yes I know this sounds
ridiculous it lays one of the most
written about people of the modern era
the subject of endless movies and some
very weird erotic fiction so how come
this is not common knowledge well
there's not really a good answer for
that historians have been aware of most
of this information but never really
focused on it it took an outsider a non
historian called Norman Ola to really
pull a cover on the story and show that
Hitler's real white power who is
actually a massive bag of speed Ola a
German writer had heard a story from a
friend about drugs in the Third Reich
and decided to investigate thinking it
will be a good premise for a novel but
he soon found a wealth of information
and his non-fiction book blitz became an
international bestseller when the Nazis
took power they banned the seductive
poisons as they called them that were
readily available everywhere also
claiming that the Jewish character was
essentially drug dependent but then they
soon discovered that in Fatima pne's
were an invaluable tool to help keep the
German people productive but also to
enable our troops to stay awake the
German invasion of France relied heavily
on doses of perverted basically German
speed but enabled their army to march
without stopping for three days even by
the end of the war they plan suicide of
one man u-boat missions up the River
Thames giving the submarine pilots a
cocktail of cocaine and speed to travel
solo for days on end
none of them were ever successful low as
the dangerously high crew men docile
spun-out navigation went to hell and
they probably drowned trying to rave
with an octopus Hitler himself had a
private doctor called dr. Morel who
initially just gave him vitamin
injections but after he became ill in
1941 he took things up a notch with
animal hormones a cousin of heroin and
cocaine for a hearing problems say you
have to be careful kids you starts out
just popping vitamins and soon you're
the junkie lord of genocide drug czar
but the biggest drug in Britain as you
all know is tea I myself am a heavily
dependent at it in the early part of the
19th century the tax on imported tea
accounted for an astonishing 10% of
government revenue America had already
made their tea intentions very clear so
we were really putting our energy into
Asia at this point largely through the
world's biggest business the East India
Company he were basically running India
on the British government's behalf the
best tea came from China but they had a
lot of laws about how much we could
trade with that on top of this the East
India Company had huge debts and we knew
we could make up this deficit if we
could exploit the Chinese market somehow
in a flash of inspiration we went full
on Walter white power and decided to
sell huge quantities of opium to the
Chinese black market thanks to our
breaking Brit moment some 12 million
Chinese ended up addicted to the
powerful opiate you're welcome China was
obviously not delighted about this red
coat
Tony Montana operation and in 1839 they
tried to kick us out of the country
confiscating and burning tons of the
drug with millions of pounds the Brits
and Chinese eventually settled on a deal
where the British got an island offshore
to set up trading posts and this would
eventually become known as Hong Kong
remaining under British control in some
form until 1997 there was a second opium
war from 1856 to 1860 with the French
and Americans teaming up of the British
for a delicious slice of that drug
Empire who knew the Brits are global
drug dealers
maybe our stiff upper-lip is just
because it's covered in cocaine
according to roxy music love is the drug
and we've all been caught up in its hi
at some point the trouble is love and
sex have some complicated side effects
such as heart problems and embarrassing
rash and a closet full of super mario
outfits but since we left behind the
amoebas life in all forms have been very
focused on sticking things in other
things to create the next generation if
this is news to you then you're probably
too young to be on the internet and
please don't go googling anything in the
comment section mankind had different
ideas though we very much liked the
thing in things part but we were less
keen on the next generation bit because
we were a bit busy and we could barely
even feed ourselves let alone a small
pink version of us for thousands of
years we have been trying to find an
effective way to keep the making out of
lovemaking from 5,000 year old fish
bladder condoms to awkward diaphragms
finally and ovid came onto the market in
the u.s. in 1957 as a treatment for
menstrual disorders but by 1960 it was
licensed as a contraceptive thanks
largely to the amazing work of Margaret
Sanger who created the organizations
that became Planned Parenthood now the
pill is far from a perfect solution but
its impact on female empowerment cannot
be overstated it put women in control of
childbirth meaning they could play a far
greater part in business and politics it
was this more than its effect on
population size that really changed
society and led to the first female
president oh yeah I forgot the pill also
helped along the free love movement at
the 60s because nothing is more likely
to make you give up weed and hemp
sweaters than the cold hard reality of a
hungry child but one of the golden puffs
of the hippie generation was the
mind-altering magic of LSD
a new report I came out this year led by
British neuroscientist David nerds aptly
named it was suggested that the drug
breaks down the barriers between
separate
of the brain creating a system that is
much more integrated and this altering
of perspective has led to some of the
greatest discoveries of the 20th century
a British molecular biologist Francis
Crick was a regular LSD user when he and
James Watson discovered the structure of
DNA and changed biology forever that's
right
LSD has saved millions of lives but LS
T's multicolored dream net is from much
further than this having helped many
other great minds such as theoretical
physicist Richard Fineman mathematician
Ralph Abraham Nobel Prize winning
chemist Kary Mullis
and turtleneck model Steve Jobs so that
concludes our magical acid trip through
history kids if there's one thing that
you should take away from this video
it's don't do drugs unless you're a
teacher or a politician trust me you'll
need it thanks for the view subscribe
for more thoughty2 but in reality how
real is the American presidents power
how much power do they really possess a
man known simply as Ziona
has a grand total of 39 wives